we're already seeing and we're going to
continue to see
massive increase in gas prices and this
is going to be dramatically accelerated
because the united states will announce
today by the time you watch today's show
listen to today's podcast it may already
have been announced the u.s will ban oil
from russia and the european union plans
to reduce by two-thirds the amount of
oil purchased from russia we are already
at record high gas prices and this is
only going to get worse and i'm going to
talk about all aspects of this i'll talk
about the political
i will talk about the technological the
climate change component and the
economic uh but let's start with the big
news today the u.s is expected today to
announce a ban on russian oil
the white house updated president joe
biden's schedule to include an
announcement of additional steps the u.s
will take to hold russia accountable for
its war on ukraine those remarks will be
delivered at the white house today and
the expectation is a ban on imports of
russian oil
which would cut about eight percent of
america's annual supply now i want to
remind everybody
we hear this talking point from the
right we were energy independent under
trump and now we no longer are the truth
is that in the last couple years of
trump as well as last year under joe
biden the u.s produced as much oil as it
used but that doesn't mean we only use
our own oil some of the oil we we
produce we export and we also import so
even though total production and
consumption were roughly equal the last
couple years of trump and biden that is
true
but also oil is imported from russia
regularly it's about eight percent of uh
american oil consumption and that is
going to stop that has already caused
oil prices to spike
in addition the european union is
pledging to cut russian gas imports by
two-thirds did i say oil before i meant
to say gas the eu is pledging to cut
russian gas imports by two-thirds before
the end of the year
and that will also have an uh impact on
energy prices gas rather than oil
on top of this shell will no longer buy
russian oil nor russian gas
shell said it is breaking completely
with russia's giant energy industry
halting all purchases of russian crude
oil immediately
and shutting service stations in the
country
the uk-based company last week announced
it was dumping investments in russia
said it is abandoning all trade in
russian fossil fuels to align with
government guidance
russia is warning of 300 oil
and threatening to cut off european gas
if the west bank's energy imports
and now europe is saying well we're
cutting down by two-thirds anyway so
russia looking to escalate and threaten
and believe me i mean three i'm against
the use of fossil fuels i believe our
transition to renewables has been
pathetically slow and hindered by uh bad
or lack of policy and large oil
consuming western nations all of it and
i can't ignore
that 300 oil
and what it would do to gas prices and
home heating gasoline prices and home
heating
would be devastating to anyone who is in
a financially precarious or or even
you know balanced but not exactly a
surplus economic situation and we're
going to talk about that now we are
already seeing we are already seeing
record gas prices the average is now
right around 419 per gallon and if you
go back you know over the last 10 years
gas got close to four about 394 back in
2012. about 369 in 2014 this is the
highest that gas prices have been
in 10 years so where do we even start
um first and foremost we have to
remember
the political
how can american presidents impact gas
prices gas prices are up globally and
there are lots of people who just want
to blame joe biden this is very stupid
now fact check me on this
i don't play politics with gas prices
when gas prices are low under a democrat
i say presidents have very little to do
with gas prices when gas prices are low
under a republican i say presidents have
very little to do when gas is high under
a republican or a democratic president i
say presidents don't have very much to
do with gas prices fact check me on it
this is a very dumb political football
what can presidents do to impact gas
prices okay
one an american president can say we're
going to war
against an oil producing country
usually that raises gas prices uh when
we go to war with a country that
produces oil it's
potentially going to disrupt the supply
so when an american president says let's
invade like for example you know the
first iraq war
prices tend to go up number two
a president can change gasoline taxes
raise or lower and they can't
unilaterally do it but a president can
advocate for that
uh and if gas taxes go up then gas
prices go up and okay so that's number
two and then number three and this is
the most commonly discussed one there's
this thing called the strategic
petroleum reserve
and a president can
release oil
from the strategic petroleum reserve
which will
cause a small decrease in the price of
oil and eventually gas
or or it will slow down the increase if
gas prices are increasing really quickly
so presidents can do very very little
and this is global it's happening
everywhere so if your priority is
blaming biden
i don't even want to hear from you
because it's just not
even substantive
the more pressing question is number one
um this again exposes
how
humiliatingly
woefully behind we have been on getting
off of oil now i know it's like oh
you're going to do that you're going to
do you're going to be that guy david i
understand
that transitioning off of oil takes time
transitioning off of natural gas takes
time putting solar panels on roofs
and having electric
heating and cooking
and electric cars so that you get off
fossil fuels other than for the
production of all of the stuff that you
use i get that that takes time but we
also need to remember that we didn't
make much progress under obama we didn't
make almost any progress under trump
we continue to have completely
inaccurate gas prices in other words our
gas prices don't even come close to
reflecting
the true cost of gasoline
uh on the environment and on the economy
and on society so it we're just it's
been pathetic
and i also understand how if you're a
family that like 40
of families in the united states
can't meet an unexpected 400 expense
without
taking down on debt putting on a credit
card or whatever
i understand that if gas prices go up to
five six dollars a gallon which 520 is
one of the numbers that's being thrown
around average gallon could go to 520.
and you need heating oil to heat your
home because you don't have one of these
new fancy electric heat pumps and solar
panels and all you're still paying for
oil
i get how you'll probably end up going
into debt just to fuel your car
and heat your home so we can hold both
at the same time but let's at least be
accurate in terms of uh who is to blame
for this
and the real role of presidents and once
the announcement is made and more
accurate forecasts are made
we will follow that up
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone but i left
my wallet somewhere i don't have my real
credit card on me i can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video